the supply we do have will
still enable us to hit the targets we
have set
that means that by the 15th of april
we'll be able to offer a first
dose to all of you who are over 50
as well as those under 50 who are
clinically
vulnerable we will have the second doses
that people need
within the 12-week window which means
around
12 million people in april and
we will still offer a first dose to
every adult
by the end of july so there is no
change to the next steps of
the roadmap we've now vaccinated over 25
million people across
our entire united kingdom more than the
entire population
of many countries and our progress along
the road to freedom
continues unchecked we remain on track
to reclaim the things we love to see our
families
and friends again to return to our local
pubs our gyms
and sports facilities and of course
our shops all of course as long as the
data continue to go in the right
direction and
we meet our four tests and
the way to ensure that this happens is
to
get that jab when your turn comes so
let's get the jab done